- I introduce weird
tropical fruit to people
from every corner of the world.
It's the most amazing thing.
There's sugar apples, annoan.
I got manzanos.
Sapidilla, the sweetest fruit.
It's like a pear with brown sugar.
It's just a religious
experience eating this fruit.
- [Narrator] This is Robert,
right here,
and here.
Here he is,
- My name is Robert Moehling
and I own Robert Is Here.
A little bit of a landmark
here for over 60 years.
- [Narrator] At six years
old Robert started selling
regular produce.
- [Robert] My dad was
farming down in South Florida
and he was not doin' as well
as could have been done.
- [Narrator] So his dad put out a sign
that said Robert is here
as a marketing technique.
And Robert is still here.
Customers stopped for the cute kid
and stayed for the great fruit.
- Dad kept on farming till I was about 14
and then he sold all of his equipment
and didn't farm anymore.
At about 14 I bought this property.
I worked on my farm,
by myself doing most of the
tractor work and spraying
and everything else.
Now we have about 50 acres of land.
Farm animanls.
Booming fruit stand and a great crew.
- [Narrator] Ever since a
neighbor introduced Robert
to fruits like papaya,
mango, and guanabana,
Robert fell in love
with the exotic flavors
and wanted to share them with
anyone who came to his stand.
- We have jackfruit,
canistel, mamoncillos,
which is a Spanish lime,
rambutan, lychees and langans.
Oh the guanabana.
Gosh there's so many.
- [Narrator] South Florida
is one of the only climates
that can grow so many tropical
fruits all in one place.
Today Robert can sell up to
50 varieties at one time.
- When it's in season
everything's grown right here.
- [Narrator] What was once
a small operation is now
a family business.
And for Robert sharing his
passion with his family
has made all the difference.
- The whole family is on the market now.
Runnin' in.
I work really hard and I want my family
to work really hard and still have fun.
My aim is to be the best farm
market ever on the planet
and I'm not far from it.